Religion is sometimes thought of as the sworn
enemy of science, but can we actually use
science to better understand religion?
Now I’m not trying to get into a religious
debate here, so put your Twitter fingers away, alright?
Using neuroscience, we can dive into how religion
is recognized by the brain.
But first, let’s define a few things: Religion
is a set of beliefs and those beliefs are
correlated with activation of different parts
of our brains.
That brings us to theory of mind.
Theory of mind is our ability to interpret
one's own and other people's emotional and
mental states — including
our desires and beliefs.
Which means, religion and theory of mind may
be connected by people’s ability to imagine
a reality beyond one's own immediate sensory experience.
If that’s true, then the same parts of the
brain that activate during theory of mind
tests will also activate when thinking about
G-O-D.
And that’s just what scientists have found.
When researchers asked people about theory
of mind tasks or to think about religion,
the same regions of the brain lit up when
put under an fMRI, and neurotheologists –– the
folks who study the intersection of religion
and neuroscience –– are interested in
why those parts light up.
According to fMRI data, the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex, the anterior cingulate gyrus, the
nucleus accumbens, and the parietal lobe are
all affected when subjects are prompted about
religion.
In a study where 15 Christians and 15 “non-believers”
were asked about the existence of the big
G, the ventromedial prefrontal cortex lit
up in all participants.
This region of the brain is specifically responsible
for reward and perception of self-relevance.
Remember “rewards” because we’ll come
back to that.
Another region that lit up was the anterior cingulate gyrus.
This part of the brain is thought to modulate
conflict, errors, and violations of our expectations.
This suggests there was a degree of internal
conflict when subjects were asked to think
about a higher power.
Even non-believers had this area light up,
because whether they chose Yahweh or the highway,
they were still experiencing some type of
uncertainty.
In 2016, another study found that when Mormon
participants were in the midst of an intense
religious experience, it increased their heart
rates and activated parts of their brains
linked to rewards...the same way sex and drugs
do.
Please don’t excommunicate me.
This is science, I swear.
The state is actually called “religious
euphoria” or “religious ecstasy.”
The nucleus accumbens, specifically, lit up
like a Christmas Tree ... which is another
reward center just like the the ventromedial
pre (oh my God this is so much to say I’m
just gonna say VMPFC, which is almost worse).
A 2010 study found that during religious activity,
there was a decrease in activity in the parietal
lobe, which processes physical sensory stimuli.
Meaning, when people think about God, they’re
potentially experiencing a feeling of being
somewhat detached from their physical body.
Does this mean those of us who practice a
religion are succumbing to a higher power?
Letting the Force flow through us, perhaps?
More research definitely needed.
(If I could be a Jedi, I absolutely wouldn’t
be here talking to y’all.
I say that as a friend.
Moving things in my house.)
Science and religion seem to be like Azealia
Banks and staying out of drama but rather
than have them constantly at odds, perhaps
look at religion as a thing that developed
as part of human social cognition and behavior
over our evolutionary history.
The development of our prefrontal cortex over
generations allows us to have that abstract,
existential, and/or religious thought.
And that’s an important part of what makes
us ‘human’-- as our brains were advancing
physically, religion and other belief systems
came about to help us connect and understand
each other.
One common theme across religion is prosociality,
basically “love thy neighbor;” we relate
to one another through what we believe.
And even if your beliefs are different from
your neighbors’, just remember ‘Theory
of Mind’ — our brains have the capacity
to understand and interpret their thoughts
and perspectives, so just be good to each
other is all!
(Oh, and find out if midichlorians are real
and if they’re found in the parietal lobe
‘cause I’m really trying to use the Force
to clean my apartment.
Laundry.
Clean.)
Yo, did someone say pray…ing mantis?
I’m pretty someone in here said praying
mantis.
If you want to find out more about praying
mantises, check out this video right here
on the mating rituals of the praying mantis.
And don’t forget to subscribe to Seeker
for answers to all the questions you never
knew you had!
We have them.
We have all the answers.